hey guys and welcome to another one of
my bond from scratch videos we're going
to be doing another payt tolay one today
since you guys did seem to enjoy the
last one uh once again we are going to
be giving away the bond so to enter all
you have to do is be subscribed uh leave
a comment in the video section and toss
a like and that is all guys so hope you
enjoy the video and let's get started so
for those of you who watched my last
episode of T bond from scratch or
whatever you want to call it uh you may
remember this account It's My Level 32
Bond account now it is not at level
three anymore unfortunately um but it is
very low level honestly all it has is
some magic levels and HP levels and
that's pretty much it any of the stats
are negligible as far as inventory
nothing in the inventory Bank uh we just
have some useless items and some
untradeable things like looting bag that
might come in handy um but yeah so
pretty much wipe the account nothing on
it and we're going to start fresh now we
have an hour uh timer set for 10 hours
um hopefully won't take that long but
we're not going to want it to take
longer than that or we may just give up
so without further Ado let's get
started so again once again we will
again once again we will need an item uh
so we're just going to kind of pick up
some random stuff off the ground beer
glass probably worthless but we'll pick
it up anyway uh cuz we literally have
zero GP we need something to sell in the
grand exchange and well ashes I guess
that'll do uh the first thing we're
going to do is going to require a lot
less money than the previous time we did
this actually this is selling for a
decent amount 75 coins that's nice ashes
sell those off just quickly do a scan to
see if anything's else in the gr
exchange and doesn't look like it so
that's a good starter cash base uh
really only took 20 seconds another a
beard glass maybe we're going to stick
here and pick up a few more just because
they do seem to be worth actually good
amount and we'll get up to about 1K and
that'll be perfect to start with our
second Method All right so we have 727
coins and we manag to pick up a couple
more beer glasses and um couple ashes
and a cocktail glass that it was worth
[__] all but that's okay we got 1.5k
that is good so we're going to go ahead
and start off by buying some law runes
uh just for a couple teleports that
we're going to want now we're going to
buy
Six uh we don't need actually much money
to buy the item from the store although
and we'll go for five so we'll need a
little bit more money for air runes so
we'll get about 20 air
runes and we'll need a water Rune we'll
buy five water runes
and uh fire Rune or two just to get back
to the rock this is pretty important
otherwise we get to walk back and waste
a whole bunch of time that'll leave us
with 384 coins that should be good going
to bank most of this stuff here uh
actually we only need to bank our fire
runes cuz we won't need those right now
and we're going to teleport to fador and
we're going to first off run to the
herblore shop and buy the pestl mortar
from the herblore shop uh one of you may
have some of you may have noticed uh
that I actually did make a quick video
kind of related to that a while ago uh
if you have a look at the herblore
shop you can see that the pestl and
mortar are worth 492 coins roughly and
they buy for about five now this is a
really easy way to get cash early in the
game when you don't have very much money
clearly only have 462 coins so we're
going to get that a shot and do a couple
inventories all right guys so we're at
Jag X's or Jag x what is his name jtic
JX very close we're at his herbl shop
and we're just buying out the pestl and
mortars there's three in each world and
then we're just going to hop uh this is
our fourth inventory so far so used up
every single Rune so far except for the
one we'll use to get back to ver Rock
and this should be pretty much it uh
we're about 20 minutes in so far all
right that's good uh we got probably
close-ish to 100 and then we'll go back
to verac and we'll see how much these
actually sell for they usually sell for
close to 4 to 500 uh which would be
pretty nice that would be uh about 40K
uh which will help us quite a bit to
start off a couple other money makers
the next one we're going to try is
buying uh clothing items from The Gnome
tree stronghold uh the Grand Tree to be
precise is where it is now I've done
this once before and uh since they sell
clue scroll required items uh they can
actually sell for up to a k per boot you
buy so it's actually pretty nice anyway
we're back to the Grand exchange uh well
with draw 95 pestl and mortars and we'll
go ahead and just sell one of these so
far wait a sec I did not crank that the
right way uh sell it see how low it
sells for 445 that's pretty good we'll
try well actually I'm pretty happy with
that we'll just sell the one now just
and buy one back just to see if we
wouldn't get a better price otherwise
pestl and mortar and they are if we wait
going to sell for
$491 all right we'll just sell those off
then for
445 and yeah that looks good okay we
sold most of them or half of them anyway
so that is 16k we can get there nice and
now we're going to move on to the next
method okay so we finally got to The
Gnome stronghold now how we got here was
by pulling the ardun lever or the U Edge
lever going to the Wilderness and then
teleporting back to ardun and walking is
pretty far away unfortunately there's no
quicker way but anyway we made it to the
trome stronghold so we're at the Grand
Tree so what we're looking for is just
on the first floor of the Grand Tree uh
we'll have to go grab some money first
uh so the bank's just down here
hopefully nothing is locked okay so we
have 18K cash after selling off uh well
the majority of our mortars pass mortar
and all we're going to do is run up here
and there should be another gnome around
here called red or well anyway he owns
the cloth shop what is it yeah Redi and
what we're going to be buying are some
of these fashionable fine fashionable
items uh what we're going to be buying
are the blue boots the green boots and
the green R Top um we use this just by
looking on G tracker to see which ones
were worth the most and sold more
consistently like 300 every day it's
pretty consistent honestly so green rope
top green boots and blue boots These are
clue scroll items that you need uh so
they are definitely worth buying so
we're looking for the green robe top was
it Green Road top and blue and green
boot so we're definitely just going to
go ahead and buy five of
these and five of
these and five of these so we're getting
a ton of items per world and then we're
just going to hop so we only have to do
two World Toops roughly and to fill up
our inventory which is awesome and uh
well once again Buy all the green Rob
tops I think these are worth the most
and then blue and green boots are pretty
similar made two World Toops we are
already filled out our inventory uh if
we price check it now well we're
somewhere between 35k and yeah we're
just going to bank it we'll use our
money up very quickly but we'll probably
come back and do some more runs of this
okay we're on the last of our cash uh we
only have 657 coins left going to buy
the rest of the green rope tops that's
all we can afford guys so we're going to
run back and Bank us
it only took probably like 4 minutes to
buy out this shop or buy out all our
cash worth of items anyway uh we didn't
have very much cash but anyway we'll go
ahead and sell this the only problem
with this is currently it's a pain in
the ass to get back here so that is a
little bit of an issue but either way
we'll teleport back to
verac and we might as well just withd
draw the items out while we're here blue
boots and green
boots so I think we should be getting
close to 100K in profit here well I
don't know about profit let's just price
check this for you guys quickly uh it
says
76k make it more make it less we'll have
to see uh we have about about 100
quantity of items and well yeah they
probably won't go for 1K each but still
uh only took me like 5 minutes honestly
so quick and now we do have to be
careful cuz these don't sell they do
sell a fair amount but they're not going
to instantly sell by any means and we'll
get our money out cuz we might that as
well
113 coins never mind anyway so let's go
ahead and sell hey we got all the pestl
morar sold nice that's another 22k there
and we'll go ahead and sell one of these
off see what price we sell it
for looks like for 766 coins and green
robe top is it worth
waiting um we'll just sell these off for
766 that's fine with me 25k there and
the blue
boots are going to be selling for
764 that is good with
me going to be another 25k there and
green
boots are going to be selling
for uh
668 that is fine as well
so unfortunately these haven't sold too
much oh we got more there actually uh so
we have another 36k that's probably
worth going back and buying some more of
these cuz overall we're probably going
to
get well yeah close to 75k in that it
only took like five minutes to buy all
those items uh so I think that's pretty
reasonable we'll go back and do at least
one more run and then move on to
something
else okay so we finished up a couple
inventories here and I kind of just come
to realize that these might not sell
that quickly so we're going to go ahead
and just Bank this and uh just finish
this up for that method uh really good
when you're just starting off a brand
new account uh because there's no
requirements is a pain to get here but
the items are pretty cheap and you get a
really good return on them uh but anyway
we will need a little bit of cash to
start the next one and uh unfortunately
will take a while to sell of course we
are going to be here for a while so they
should sell in time uh what we're going
to do next is actually kill lava dragons
uh on top of that we're also going to
pick white berries the majority of the
profit is going to come from the white
berries but killing the lava dragons
also has a chance of getting something
good either can get the onx bolt tips or
really any alol is good as well uh so
we'll just withdraw all of these items
as well going to be another 100K roughly
worth of items once they sell off we'll
put them in there for 766 as
well that's
perfect and Bob these in for
763 honestly we should probably just
make another offer slot
pop thism for
668 and do
667 uh just for the funds and
um wait where's our money there we go uh
so what we're going to need is we
already have the Looting bag which is
nice uh we're going to need a staff of
fire staff of
fire going to need a wizard robes wow
that didn't wizard
robe and that's kind of expensive
too and yeah so we'll go anyway we'll
just go buy the items we need just to
get a basic mage setup not a whole lot
just a bit of magic bonus so we can go
range our Mage some of the lava dragons
and grab the Looting bag and we'll go
and start the method all right guys so
we're out here in the wilderness killing
lava dragons this is kind of risky but
of course we're in the newbies gear
possible so we're not really risking a
lot so you might notice what we're doing
is we're attacking twice and then we're
going to pick up the white Berry and
occasionally we're going to toss them
into our bag which unfortunately can't
do perfectly on the tick but either way
uh you're not missing much by picking up
the white berries or you're not missing
much by attacking the lava dragons uh so
you're not really missing much out at
all and we're going to get an
extra 15 to 20K a trip because we'll get
one lava dragon kill per trip even with
fire strike even with terrible magic
levels you'll eventually get a kill and
we'll be back once uh well I guess we'll
do this for an hour to start
with okay so here's the first uh loot we
got um one other thing worth mentioning
is that having a very low combat level
is so useful here because right now all
I have is 51 magic and that's all uh so
my combat level is really low
comparative to my stats at least to my
combat magic level uh so I saw about
three pkers but they're all level 90
plus even 100 plus so honestly none of
them could attack me so it's extremely
useful probably not even going to have
to worry about pees for this account in
particular and yeah so definitely if
you're a low level go ahead and do it as
far as what we got in loot we got about
uh
65k and that took
about 8 10 minutes probably could do
that a little quicker uh but of course
we recording and everything makes it a
little bit slower so we could probably
get that down to about 8 minutes so 60k
in 8 minutes is pretty good that's going
to be 500 600k an hour and yeah so we'll
go ahead do this for the first hour and
then we'll come back and show you the
loot and then we may even do it for a
second
hour okay guys we're just finishing up
our hour of killing lava dragons and
picking up the white berries uh we
stayed for an extra couple kills well I
guess one extra kill uh we managed to
get 10 will this will be our 10th kill
in an hour uh it's pretty damn slow uh
but uh well we got the white berries
anyway probably got close to 400 white
berries and I think our looting bag is
full isn't it oh it's not
whoopsies uh that was a mistake anyway
we will just have to pick up a couple
more white berries uh but we're just
about to get the last lava dragon kill I
thought I'd get on film because they
take a [__] long time to kill
unfortunately what are we going to get
and more item
bars not very good but at least that
fills up all our inventory
slots and yeah we're going to head it
out of here and we'll see how much we
actually got in one hour see all the
loot okay so we're back at the Grand
exchange uh so first of all let's just
look at our exchange looks like the blue
boots have all sold and I thought those
would sell first um the green rope tops
are still in the process of selling uh
well 16k more those and green boots are
coming through uh not super quick but
that is 77k honestly right there which
is pretty good now for what we got from
lava dragons we actually got 350 on the
dot white berries and we got 10 kills so
let's draw the bones the lava skills
Rune javins and run darts we got a
couple of those run kite Shield
RAR and uh dragon javelins I guess were
the best dropping out honestly not that
good wait is there stuff in the Looting
bag
still ah okay forgot things in moving
bag whoops uh we deposit those I guess
we got a little bit more than
350 378 it looks like that's pretty good
actually considering we didn't even get
a rare drop at all we didn't get the onx
bolt tips uh or anything like that I'd
say that's a pretty good run we'll
definitely just going to insta sell
things for now and the rest of these
things are going to get sold off so
that's actually really good the lava
dragons actually killing them probably
buffed the money maker by an extra 200k
an hour or something like that and we
didn't even get a drop so that's very
good collect and 681k normally You' get
about 500k just picking the white
berries so definitely going to continue
doing this that's going to bring our
total cash deck up to boat 761k which is
pretty good I mean we're two and a half
hours in and but finally we got a good
money maker we're going to go ahead and
do one more hour of this and see where
we're at we are back and I do realize
it's been 2 hours uh we did have a bit
of a change of heart what we ended up
doing was just just picking the white
berries uh the reason I did that is cuz
I wanted to see the difference in the GP
per hour compared to when you're killing
the lava dragons versus when you're not
killing them uh when you are killing
them I got about 700k now in the 2 hours
it's been I managed to get 776 white
berries so let's see how much those are
worth and uh we will kind of need to
sell them off quick but we will maybe
price check them first just if there's a
major difference we may wait but
otherwise we're going to instant sell
them uh cuz that's a fair amount of our
cash Jack just some white berries there
and actually we got some money in the
green boots and the green rope tops
almost sold off so white berries and
they are going
for 1349 into what we would insta sell
them for is roughly 1255 so is a fair
difference uh so we'll put them in there
for
1348 for now I give this about 1 mil in
profit so about 500k an hour versus 700k
an hour I would say it's worth fire
striking the
lava dragons but that's just me so we'll
just wait for these to sell cuz they
should sell pretty
quick okay we're back in the white
berries did sell uh took about 10
minutes and uh I wouldn't normally do
this but they didn't take long to sell
and I'd say it's worth having the cash
so we can start the next method which is
going to be a classic one uh but buying
um green Dragonites and Tanning them uh
easy 400 500k an hour uh no requirements
except for money of course so what you
need is green Dragon hide of course and
uh dream dragon hide going to buy and
sell one so
and 1730 that's I guess we'll wait
I guess we'll buy uh for 17 is the 15
coins worth it I would say no in this
case we're just going to go ahead and uh
buy it for
1745 uh because the time is not going to
be worth to wait I don't think now we
couldn't
quite do 1K I'm going to do 900 cuz you
do need some coins left over to actually
tan them so 1746 there we go
instabot and we will also want a ring of
dueling and I believe a stamina potion
will probably be worth it here buy a
couple stamina
potions and a few energy potions as
well
okay so we be all set to go just put on
our ring of dueling and we're going to
start tanning the hides so I guess we
might as well bring an inventory with us
uh but it's honly just the easiest thing
in the world we're going to go to
alarid and from here we're just going to
run south towards the agility shortcut
here and the Tannery or the tanning
station or whatever you want to call it
and we're going to run in here and we'll
just do it before and after check just
to see what how profitable is right now
uh so before get that map out of the way
our profit is going to be
302 K and change and so if we trade and
create all green
dragony our inventory is going to be
worth
38351 and just to check again so we're
at the bank and we'll just check price
check an inventory of um the tan tide so
52 and 500 and before the coin are the
dragon hid's going to be
[Music]
worth
46 540 plus a little bit of coins of
course but that is a decent amount per
run so we're going to go ahead and do
this um well we'll can all these hides
and we'll be back in a minute uh so
luckily we can um pretty much insta sell
and insta buy the green dragon leather
so we're not wasting too much time in
the grand exchange uh because we don't
have enough money to do this for a full
hour we only took 20 minutes to tanel
these Dragon hides uh so we did all 900
and we'll be netting I guess about 200k
in profit there and we also did sell off
the green boots and green robes so we're
at about 2 mil so we're going to go
ahead and repeat this at least two more
times uh because we need probably 2.5
mil to 2.6 mil to buy a bond so we'll go
ahead and buy some more green dragon
hide guess this time we can afford a bit
more green dragon
and we're going to insta again probably
don't need to go that
high and we'll do 1,000 this
time 1,000 this time there we go bought
them all for 1745 perfect same price as
last time and we'll go ahead and tan
them
all uh so I ended up doing the green
dragon hides all the way to the bond if
we have a look at my history here uh we
can see that we bought Green Dragon hies
for for
1944 uh sorry that's what we sold them
for we bought them for 1970 and sold for
1944 and we did this well there's a
first 900 we sold and then 1,000 1,000
so that's one run of 1,000 and two runs
of 1,000 and now we just did one of 1200
we're going to go back and sell it and
hopefully we'll have enough for Bond I
can't really tell 1944 will they sell
for that much yes so that's 2549 I don't
know if that's actually enough or
not all right we got some stamas in the
bank we're going to liquidate everything
we have that's of any value we got glory
and I guess that's about it so we'll go
ahead and sell that stuff off maybe
it'll be enough I think bonds are
between 26 and 2.6 and 2.7 mil so maybe
we can snag one for the lower
end
so after all said and done our final
cash Jack is 2586 let's just see if we
can snag one for 2586 otherwise we may
have to do a flipper
to 2586 can we get the bond No we cannot
all right we're going to have to do a
flip all right we have a flip coming
through uh just some Snap Dragon seeds
uh we bought them
for uh 2197 and we're going to sell them
for 2 two three fours only a 30k flip
well let's try to buy the bond
again maybe that was just enough I doubt
it because the actually trade price is
much higher 2629 any luck on 2629
doesn't look like it we'll have to go
for another
flip all right guys I think this might
be it man am I getting tired but I think
this final flip should be enough we got
a really nice flip on bow strings we
bought them for $
12249 and we're selling them for 1416
that's amazing
2796 please be enough for a bond or I'm
going to freak
out
2796 please hit me out with that
Bond yeah there it is finally we bought
for 2680 and that's it guys so I really
hope you enjoyed again there is going to
be a giveaway for the bond so don't
forget to enter uh and I hope you have a
wonderful night
bye